[Music]
hey there and welcome to this bonus
lesson on um
tracking in after effects this is about
content aware fill which is a newer
feature of after effects
depending on when you're watching this
so
what content aware does is it can remove
objects from your footage that you don't
want there anymore and it does this by
tracking you have to track the footage
and then it kind of fills in that track
with uh new footage essentially that it
it creates
so it's really easy to use content aware
um some people get kind of caught up in
the how to actually use it
but sometimes i can do an amazing job
sometimes it doesn't work so great
for this particular example we're going
to make it look great so what i have
here is my footage and you can see i
have a mask that i drew around this car
so what i want is i want this car which
is right here i want this car
to go away i don't want it in the shot
for whatever reason
let's say this is supposed to be the
last car in the shot and this car is not
supposed to be there so i need it going
okay so how do i do that so
the first step is that we create a mask
and we just make a very rough mask
around our car
just like so
and with that mask selected
i can
go in and i can create
a
track so let me track forward and let me
just track this real quick
okay so it's tracked the mask follows
the car the whole way
looks great so how do we use content
aware it's really easy you go up to
window you go down to content aware fill
boom there it is and let's actually go
ahead and just bring this
over here
and i'm going to expand this window we
don't really need to but i'll expand it
anyways so what do we do here we say we
want to replace we want to fill
this
street we want to fill the object okay
we want to fill the object we want to
replace it with our work area which is
actually the full composition
and before it can work i have to say hey
this mask is subtracted there's nothing
there i need to fill
this with an object
then all i do is click generate fill
layer and it starts to do its magic and
you're going to see here it says
analyzing it can sometimes take a long
time depending on how long your shot is
how much fill has to be created
so let's just stand by and let it do its
thing
and then once it has created a fill it's
actually going to render and you can see
the fill right here it's all filled in
it's going to render this
across the sequence and
essentially fill it in okay so it has
created a fill and you're going to see
here this is the png sequence right so
you do want to be uh aware of where you
save your project file because this png
sequence will be saved
wherever that project file is saved at
so we're just going to play back here
and we're going to see how this actually
looks
i see a couple of artifacts in here
which you may or may not be able to see
but the car is somewhere up in here now
which i'm not seeing any artifacts here
which is great
i'm just kind of watching um a lot of
times you know watching this stuff frame
by frame as a previews is great because
it uh
it's better for us to
[Music]
get an idea of what's actually happening
so right there that's all
jacked up right
so we'll have to fix that
[Music]
and a way to fix that which that's a
really trippy
thing that happens there
so what i think would work here is the
fact that we're not scaling we're not
using we're only using position we're
not using scale to track the car and
that's why up in here you can see the
mass stays too large right and the the
mass is the same size here as it is here
and by the time it gets to this point
the mass should be much smaller so if we
apply
if we track the
scale
with the position so position and scale
and looks like rotation as well
that will probably
solve our problem so let's see what
happens by tracking position scale and
rotation and let's retract that
and let's go ahead and turn the fill off
here and let's just back it up
i think that might work let's
[Music]
try one more thing let's try position
scale
rotation and skew and let's see if that
does it
yeah i think that's going to do it let's
make sure it's set to subtract
it's there
and let's go ahead now and go to our
content aware and let's just delete the
fill that was there
make sure we're selected and say
generate fill layer and let's see what
happens
okay so if we take a look at
this now
yeah that seems to have solved the
problem so let's go ahead and preview
this
everything's looking great
it's got a really nice track to it
just by adding the rotation scale and
skew
looks like the track is right on
the car in front still looks good
and there we go so that was the
solve to our problem
we had to track more than just position
we had to include scale rotation and
skew
so i hope that you learned how powerful
it is to use mass tracking with content
aware fill
two powerful combos
that can remove objects from your
footage
with that that's going to wrap up the 2d
3d and stabilizing
lessons in the series and with that
being said let's move on
[Music]
you